madame monsieur bonsoir près de deux
heures d'une remontée triomphale des
champs-elysées 600000 personnes
attendaient les bleus cet après-midi sur
la plus belle avenue du monde les bleus
et leur entraîneur aimé jacquet pour un
triomphe jamais vu et qui n'a même pas
pu se terminer sous 10 et sur la place
de l'étoile il y avait trop de monde les
malaises dans la foule et les
ordinateurs ont préféré écourter le
trajet le récit de pascal golomer et
jean paul chaussée ils s'étaient donné
rendez vous en cette belle après-midi
d'été sur les champs elysées et quel
rendez vous un moment exceptionnel un de
plus
d'un côté les joueurs de l'équipe de
france voulait montrer à leur public
cette coupe du monde dont ils ne peuvent
plus se séparer de l'autre le public
ces dizaines de milliers de supporters
cinq cent mille six cent mille peut-être
de tous âges de toutes races voulait
dire merci aux bleus merci à zizou à
m'aimer et à tous les autres
l'autobus à impériale voyez dans la
foule n'avancent plus guère et l'arc de
triomphe est encore loin mais qu'importe
sourire et main tendue la victoire est
si belle à partager
oublié le petit carnet de notes et les
consignes technico tactique
aimé jacquet savoure l'instant et il
laisse à ses joueurs le soin de veiller
sur la coupe
il peut leur faire confiance
tout le monde se dit merci tout le monde
se dit bravo et à la prochaine fois plus
question de se séparer
c'est une belle histoire d'amour entre
22 joueurs de football
perché sur un autobus et le peuple de
france rassemblés sur une avenue
une histoire qui ne fait que commencer
espérons le